joining us from New York is the former
White House communications director
under Donald Trump Anthony scaramouche
II thanks very much for joining us so
how do you think your former boss
president Trump is doing with this
crisis well you know I don't want to be
a Monday Morning Quarterback in judgment
with hindsight I would say about nine or
ten days ago he made a 180 degree turn
which i think is very favorable Governor
Cuomo said yesterday in his press
conference that he's getting a lot of
help from the president and so I think
is a group of people we all have to pull
together no matter what our
disagreements are right now
I do wish though that the president had
listened to the pandemic experts and the
people at NIH the National Institute of
Health and started putting these
protocols in place in February because
then the lines of contagion in the
United States would have looked very
similar to South Korea or Singapore but
we're we're gonna go through the worst
part of this in New York in probably two
or three weeks and it's very bad now we
look like a war zone here yeah but he is
now throwing money at it he's extending
the shutdown and he's doing what most
world leaders seemed to be doing now
isn't he yeah and I I agree with that
and I think his press conference on
Sunday there was a sigh of relief up
here in New York because in the prior
week he was talking about returning the
economy back to full activity after
Easter Sunday or on Easter Sunday and I
think he got word from his people that
that would probably lead to several
hundred thousand deaths which we don't
want here I think the CDC projection
right now given that 75% of the
population is being isolated is
something like eighty thousand deaths
think of the tragedy of that we're
hoping and praying that we can keep this
thing suppressed my good friend Governor
Cuomo's younger brother Chris Cuomo who
was a commentator on CNN has the virus
and his self quarantine eing in his
house so unfortunately now if you live
here in New York you know
people that have the virus and even more
tragically you know people that have
passed from the virus you know them
personally so what should in your view
the president be doing that he's not
doing well I mean listen I'm a big
believer in a crisis you go to the best
people and I and I would have done three
things a little bit differently number
one I probably would have been more
unified with the nation's governors I
would have probably been less sensitive
or thin-skinned to whatever their
reactions were number two you've got
places like Florida that have not really
fully shut down and there's a lot of
elderly people in that population I
think the president could have used his
moral suasion to get that lock down and
a little bit more of a hurry and I think
of the last piece we could discuss the
stimulus it's an okay stimulus but we
really needed to push more to the
average wage earner when we did the
calculation it was sort of $3,000 per
adult and $1,500 per child and there way
below that and so I'm worried about that
for the middle and lower middle class
person in terms of their struggle as the
economy reopens and some of them may be
out of jobs and there'll be a transition
period for them to find new jobs so we
could have probably done a little bit
better on the stimulus for those people
now as you say in the city you live in
it's an appalling figure at the moment a
very grim situation there do you think
that other American cities can now
expect what New York is seeing now well
listen don't just go by me look at a
former FDA Commissioner a good friend of
mine Scott Gottlieb you could look at
these pandemic charts and the different
cities there are zones in the United
States that have more than 5,000 cases
now and that's very bad because of the
way this thing exponentially grows so we
have a problem in New Orleans we have a
problem in Detroit possibly Atlanta and
Miami and in Northern California and
Seattle so so there are problems ahead
for the United States and I hope that
people will learn from what Governor
Cuomo is doing lack
things down and keep them locked down a
little bit longer don't under react to
this crisis I think that we will learn
with hindsight that an overreaction
Kelvin kept more people safe and frankly
allowed for the economy to return back
to its flourish in a much quicker period
of time if we do these measurements
right now in these containment
measurements yeah I mean Donald Trump is
listening to his top scientific adviser
now Tony Fauci he said the other day we
had a strong argument with him now he's
listening yeah I believe that I think
that the numbers were overly
overwhelming for the president you know
one of the things the president tries to
do and it's unsuccessful here you can't
get to the microphone in the White House
or in the Rose Garden and yell out fake
science you know if two plus two equals
four the president would have a very
hard time even with his most ardent
supporters of convincing then the two
plus two is seven and so this was an
unusual crisis for this president 45
years of his mannerisms and his
communication style didn't really impact
this crisis the way he thought he
thought it would he wasn't able to curve
the reality of the science to what he
wanted it to be no but he his approval
rating I see today is 49 percent
disapproval 45% only the second time in
his presidency more people have approved
and disapproved and 60% approving his
handling of the crisis yeah that doesn't
surprise me at all because if you go
back to the Gulf War with George Herbert
Walker Bush it was at 90% he wouldn't
lost that election eight or nine months
later if you go through wartime
situations in the United States the
proclivity is to rally around the flag
and offer the support to the President
and so it'll be interesting to see what
people remember in November in terms of
the electoral prospects for the
president but I understand why those
approval ratings are high and I think as
an American and being a patriot first
a partisan deep last I want him to do
well in this crisis I want him to be
thinking clearly and I want him to
motivate these other cities to just take
a look at what's going on in New York
right now and please listen to the
public health care officials so that we
can lock down those cities to prevent
the tragedy or at least the volume of
the tragedy that's happening in New York
right now so I think there's no I don't
think there's any American that's for or
against President Trump that doesn't
want him to succeed right now okay and
just finally in your city Governor Cuomo
is making something of an impact with
these daily news conferences people
already talking about him as a possible
presidential contender what do you make
of that well you know I grew up with
Governor Cuomo Chris and Andrew have
been friends of mine for 40 years which
I'm sort of lying about my age now is I
don't like saying that but he's one of
my closest friends he's a great guy he
is not an armchair general he's out
there on the frontlines and I pray for
him every day because I know he's in
touch with a lot of people that are
infected with the disease and so could
he be president sure he would be an
amazing president but he said very very
clearly one of his best friends and
politics and his political mentor is
Vice President Joe Biden he endorsed
some early and I think he's gonna put
the full weight of his support and his
newfound popularity and his very high
approval rating let's just mention his
while we're on the air it's 87 percent
okay so I think there's a future
presidency or opportunity in his in his
future okay we're going to lose the line
so thank you very much but I wish the
people of New York in this crisis thanks
very much Anthony scary Qi thank you sir